My name is Lauren Mitchell and I'm an Australian gymnast.
I've been doing gymnastics for about 14 years now, going towards London 2012 Olympics.
A normal training day for me would be getting up at 5:30 in the morning,...
...having breakfast, going to training for about three hours,...
...and then I either have Pilates, or work or uni.
And then go back in the afternoon for about three and a half hours,...
...and then go home, eat dinner, go to bed, ready for the next day.
I guess the one thing that I sacrifice is probably my schooling and my social life, a little bit.
I guess what drives me to compete is I'm kind of a perfectionist.
And I always want to be better than the person before me.
Our training regime at the moment, I'm preparing for little competitions here and there.
But overall, we'll have a really good solid six weeks right before London...
...where we just knuckle down and do routine, routine, routine and...
...just kind of get it all perfect and perfect it just then.
For me, I think it's a real mental game,...
...because you have the training and the workload is all behind you.
It's just how you can handle yourself in the competition and performance phase.
A sponsor like Visa has been fantastic, not only for me but for my family...
...and for my coaches and the whole gymnastics community.
Just so that we are able to get recognized and I'm able to get recognized.
And help us get on with our job and just focus on what we need to do...
...rather than all the other outside factors.
Yeah, it's been really helpful in that way.